[Música]
[Aplausos]
qué pasa cuando las generaciones de
seres humanos a través del tiempo
replicamos acciones y no nos
cuestionamos nada al respecto para
contarte porque me hice esta pregunta es
necesario remontarnos al 2019 pues en
los primeros meses de ese año la
contaminación era muy notoria
la contaminación del aire rebasó límites
históricos esto atendiendo a la página
de la secretaría de salud de la ciudad
de mexico
cabe señalar que por esa cuestión se
activó la contingencia ambiental y hay
que añadir algo más la situación en
nuestros montes comunales fue grave pues
hubo bosque hubo quemazones en bosques y
pastizales
también recuerdo que había muchas
publicaciones en redes sociales al
respecto era casi una essen apocalíptica
de la del volcán teutli cubierto de una
neblina espesa que al fin de cuentas no
era más que contaminación recuerdo que
desde la casa de mi abuela todo el
paisaje era gris no podíamos observar
nada y hay que mencionar también que es
clásico ver por la ciudad en milpa alta
una mancha espesa entre gris y negra
pero hay que ser honestos nunca vimos
algo tan próximo o tan cerca no en
nuestra comunidad
tampoco podemos olvidar las advertencias
que nos daba el gobierno para no
realizar actividades al aire pues
nuestra salud corría riesgo recuerdo que
muchos de mis amigos mi familia
quedábamos impregnados en la cara y en
la ropa de un polvo negro que al fin de
cuentas no eran más que partículas de
contaminación
también es necesario mencionar que la
contaminación en el aire puede traernos
muchos problemas a la salud por
mencionar algunos en los más comunes
está la tos irritación de los ojos de la
garganta de la nariz se agravan las
enfermedades cardiorrespiratorias y
cardiovasculares y esto bueno no es lo
peor no al final de cuentas la
contaminación en el aire también trae
problemas agravando el efecto
invernadero pero hay que señalar una
cosa el efecto invernadero es un
fenómeno natural
básicamente hay gases en la atmósfera
que retiene la energía reflejada por el
suelo y esto hace que la temperatura en
el planeta aumente el problema es que
las actividades humanas han hecho que la
concentración de estos gases sea mayor
esto trae problemas al medio ambiente
existen el deshielo de los polos los
huracanes se vuelven más devastadores se
certifican son más fértiles lo cual
conlleva o trae problemas a la
agricultura ya la ganadería y si
consideramos que me falta es un pueblo
que se dedica principalmente a la
agricultura ya la ganadería pues trae
muchos problemas y muy serios
además la ciudad de mexico por sus
condiciones geográficas que se encuentra
a 2 mil 250 metros sobre el nivel del
mar se encuentra más expuesta a la
radiación solar y si consideramos que la
radiación es alta a partir de los 2 mil
240 metros pues imagínense cómo está
milpa alta que en algunos puntos
alcanzan casi los 2700 metros pero bueno
para que te comparto esta explicación
recuerdan que al principio de la plática
yo les había comentado que a inicios del
2019 se habían alcanzado los límites
históricos respecto a la contaminación
del aire en la ciudad de mexico bueno
nosotros somos un pueblo de tradiciones
y costumbres en esta fecha especialmente
en mayo
realizamos la fiesta de nuestro pueblo
para quienes no lo sepan
yo soy originario de san pedro atocpan
es un pueblo que se encuentra al sur de
la ciudad de mexico la fiesta de mi
pueblo es sagrada para la mayoría de las
personas que habitamos en san pedro
atocpan se realiza así ya muchísimos
años en ella nos da la oportunidad
perfecta para refrendar nuestra fe y
respeto por lo que nosotros consideramos
sagrado esta fiesta o celebración como
lo quieran ver nos da la oportunidad
perfecta para celebrar y hacer fiesta en
ella podemos invitar y esta visión
invitar a nuestros amigos y seres
queridos a degustar platillos famosos de
la región como lo pueden ser el mole con
pollo los tamales frijoles etcétera la
fiesta se arman grande en ella es
tradición quemar castillos en honor al
santo patrono de nuestro pueblo
para los que no lo sepan los castillos
son unas estructuras grandes de madera
en donde se acomodan fuegos pirotécnicos
esto a manera de que se pueda lucir un
espectáculo de luces y sonidos viendo la
situación ambiental que atravesábamos en
ese entonces a mí no se me hacía tan
viable realizar la quema de esos
castillos por fortuna para la situación
vivimos en la época de las redes
sociales y en ellas yo publiqué en un
grupo del pueblo que deberíamos
organizarnos para hablar con los
organizadores de la quema del castillo
esto con el fin de evitar la quema de
tanta pirotecnia como esperaba hubo
respuestas de todo tipo me llegaron
mensajes por redes sociales diciendo que
estaba tonto por no decir las malas
palabras que no sabía nada sobre
nuestras creencias nuestras costumbres
que no sabía nada sobre la fe y cosas
así afortunadamente también existieron
personas que respondieron positivamente
a la situación pues mucha gente demostró
y compartir ese inquietud por la cual
estábamos atravesando
de esa situación surgió un colectivo uno
enfocado a hacer o generar conciencia
del medio ambiente nuestra región ese
colectivo del cual formo parte se llama
herederos de la tierra el tema de
nuestras tradiciones y costumbres es
complejo entiendo que abordarlo no es un
tema sencillo
también entiendo que gracias a nuestras
tradiciones y costumbres claro tenemos
un sentido de pertenencia a nuestro
pueblo sin ellas perderíamos mucho
sentido y mucha
identidad como sociedad mi parte en sí
pues gracias a ellas nos auto
determinamos como un pueblo pero no
puedo ignorar el problema ambiental que
atravesábamos por ese entonces llegué a
la conclusión de que nuestras
tradiciones y costumbres no son malas
pero quizás si la manera en cómo las
estamos ejecutando pues las formas ya no
son tan compatibles con nuestros tiempos
si consideramos que cada acción que
hacemos o que realizamos repercute en
gran medida en nuestro medio ambiente
para agregar también escuchando platicas
de personas mayores y entendí y pude
saber que antes se bajaba la leña del
monte y esto hay que dejarlo claro era
una tradición de hace muchísimos años
atrás en donde no representaba ningún
problema a subir al monte a dar unos
cuantos árboles o muchos y realizar las
fiestas patronales pues en el entendido
de que la leña sirve para realizar
nuestras fiestas pues era algo necesario
pero nuestros tiempos han cambiado la
situación es distinta antes nuestros
bosques eran inmensos ahora con el paso
de los años y añadiendo prácticas como
la tala la agricultura la ganadería
desmedida que que se realiza dentro de
nuestros bosques pues en cierta medida
están deforestando mucho más nuestros
bosques y nuestras áreas verdes
también somos un pueblo de
peregrinaciones recuerdo que de pequeño
mis papás me llevaban a ellas a veces
más a la fuerza que por gusto porque un
buen mi parte ensaya fach alma caminando
no y aunque la experiencia es buena
recuerdo que también acababa un poco
decepcionado pues durante todo el camino
te puedes encontrar dos constantes
peregrinos y basura una vez mi papá
llevó a sus amigos a una peregrinación y
muchos de ellos se perdieron durante el
camino el en broma dijo escribiendo
entiendo cómo se pueden perder si no te
sabes bien la ruta únicamente sigue el
camino de basura y listo llegas y aunque
fue un chiste también encierra una
verdad pues si consideramos que no
solamente milpa alta y sus pobladores
son los únicos que realizan
peregrinaciones y consideramos también
que son muchos pobladores y de muchos
pueblos los que realizan este tipo de
actividades como visitas a chalma en el
estado de mexico guatemal 5 en morelos y
quien no ha visto de los peregrinos
escenas en donde podemos ver el cerro de
las cruces llenos de basura o parajes
rumbo a tepalcingo en donde abunda mucho
en donde abundan muchos platos y vasos
de unicel botellas de plástico nuestras
actividades incluyendo nuestras
tradiciones generan residuos quien no ha
visto las calles de nuestros pueblos o
parajes repletas de adornos para las
procesiones que se realizan en nuestros
pueblos cuantos cientos de adornos de
plástico y globos no están por nuestras
calles como basura también en nuestras
fiestas de pueblo cuantas veces hemos
visto al día siguiente calles repletas
de vasos y platos de unicel cucharas
esta plática busca generar conciencia mi
objetivo aquí no es el de erradicar las
tradiciones sencillamente es el de
cambiar el paradigma respecto a cómo
ejercemos nuestros usos y costumbres en
lugar de quemar pirotecnia en los
castillos podríamos optar por
alternativas más limpias como por
ejemplo emplear técnicas como el mapping
que es la utilización de proyectores de
vídeo para desplegar imágenes sobre
superficies esto se ha visto en
proyecciones por ejemplo en el zócalo en
el palacio de bellas artes o en
teotihuacán
también podemos optar por alternativas
para que al día siguiente de nuestras
fiestas todos esos adornos y plásticos
no terminen en nuestras calles o en
nuestra vía pública o peor en nuestras
coladeras generando inundaciones al
momento de realizar nuestras
peregrinaciones podemos organizarnos
mejor para que al realizar este tipo de
actividades no contaminemos nuestros
bosques
pues hay que ser sinceros la solución no
es llevar al personal del gobierno local
a limpiar toda esa basura creo que desde
mi punto de vista esas actividades son
negativas porque si tú llevas al
gobierno a que limpie todo lo que pienso
sea este pues de cierta manera está
reforzando la conducta de tirar basura
por donde se te ve la gana total alguien
la va a limpiar también podemos optar
por utilizar platos y vasos de uso común
en lugar de usar platos y vasos de
unicel pues así evitaremos que al día
siguiente de nuestras fiestas ensuciemos
o que todas nuestras calles amanezca en
repletas de basuras y recuerdan también
que en 2019 se rebasaron los límites
históricos de la contaminación del aire
en la ciudad de mexico
bueno pues ahí les va otra noticia en
este año 2021 se volvieron a rebasar
esos límites y ahora este año tiene el
histórico respecto a la contaminación
por partículas en el aire
esto como pueden ver es un tema que se
va agravando no hay nada de malo en que
seamos un pueblo de tradiciones y
costumbres no hay nada de malo en que
seamos peregrinos no hay nada de malo en
que seamos un pueblo que tenga fe lo
malo es que como sociedad repliquemos
acciones sin siquiera considerar el daño
que estamos haciendo positivo o negativo
creo que no debe existir una
discordancia entre nuestras tradiciones
y costumbres y cómo cuidar nuestro medio
ambiente
creo que las acciones individuales son
importantes pero también hay que
apostarle a las acciones grupales a la
organización si queremos generar un
cambio este mensaje va para todas las
personas que quieran generar ese cambio
recuerden que solo tenemos este lugar
para vivir
desafortunadamente no tenemos otro
y quizás no podemos solucionar los
problemas del mundo pero
pues podemos comenzar por mejorar en
nuestro hogar eso sí está dentro de
nuestras posibilidades que se diga que
estamos enfocados en cuidar nuestro
medio ambiente que se diga que milpa
alta también está aportando su grano de
arena así como yo haya puesto y creo en
esta idea creo que si es posible generar
ese cambio cuidemos nuestro hogar y
cuidemos nos recuerden que estar aquí si
merece la pena muchas gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]